we're asked to graph y is equal to 5 to
the x power and we'll just do this the
most basic way we'll just try out some
values for x and see what we get for y
and then we'll plot those coordinates so
let's try some negative and some
positive values and i'll try to center
them around zero so this will be my x
values this will be my y values let's
start first with something reasonably
negative but not too negative so let's
say we start with x is equal to negative
2 then y is equal to 5 to the x power or
5 to
the negative 2 power which we know is
the same thing as 1 over
5 to the positive 2 power which is just
1
25th now let's try another value what
happens when x is equal to negative 1
then y is 5
to the negative 1 power which is the
same thing as 1 over 5 to the first
power or just one one-fifth
now let's think about when x is equal to
zero then y is going to be equal to five
to the zeroth power which we know
anything to the zeroth power is going to
be equal to one
so this is going to be equal to
1.
and then finally we have well actually
let's try a couple more points here
let's try out
let me extend this table a little bit
further let's try out x is equal to 1
then y is 5 to the first power which is
just equal to 5. let's do one last value
over here let's see what happens when x
is equal to 2 then y is 5 squared
5 to the second power which is just
equal to 25 and now we can plot it to
see how this actually looks
to see how it actually looks so let me
get some graph paper going here
my x's go as low as negative 2 as high
as positive 2 and then my y's go all the
way from 1 25th all the way to 25
so let me
so i have positive values over here
so let me draw it like this so
this could be my x-axis
that could be my x-axis and then let's
make this my y-axis
draw it as neatly as i can
so let's make that my y-axis and my
x-values this could be negative 2. i
actually make my y-axis keep going so
that's y
this is x that's negative two that's
negative one
that's zero
that is one and that is positive two
and let's plot the points
x is negative 2 y is 1 25th actually let
me make the scale on the y axis so let's
make this so we're going to go all the
way to 25 so let's say that this is
5
actually i have to do a little bit
smaller than that too so this is going
to be 5
10
15
20
and then 25 would be right where i wrote
the y give or take so now let's plot
them negative 2 1 25
negative 2 1 25th 1 is going to be like
there so 1 25th is going to be really
really close to the x axis that's about
1 25th so that is negative 2
1
25th it's not going to be on the x axis
125th is obviously greater than zero
it's going to be really really really
really close
now let's do this point here in orange
negative one one-fifth negative
one-fifth one-fifth on this scale is
still pretty pretty close
it's
pretty close so that right over there is
negative one one fifth and now in blue
we have zero comma one zero comma one
is going to be right about there if this
is two and a half that looks about right
for one and then we have one comma five
1 comma 5 puts us right over there
and then finally we have 2 comma 25 when
x is 2
y is 25 2 comma 25 puts us right about
there and so i think you see what
happens with this function with this
graph it starts off the further negative
in the negative x the further in the
negative direction we go 5 to ever
increasing negative powers gets us
closer and closer to zero but never
quite so we're leaving zero getting
slightly further further further from
zero
right at the right at the y in axis we
have y equal one and then once once the
exponent over here or right at x is
equal to zero we have y is equal to one
and then one at once x starts increasing
beyond zero then we start seeing what
the exponential is good at which is just
this very rapid increase some people
would call it an exponential increase
which is obviously the case right over
here so then if i just keep this curve
going
you see it's just going on kind of this
sometimes called a hockey stick it just
keeps on going up like this at a super
fast rate ever increasing rate
so you could keep going forever to the
left and get closer and closer and
closer to zero without quite getting to
zero so five to the negative billionth
power is still not going to get you to
zero but it's gonna get you pretty darn
close to zero but obviously if you go to
five to the positive billionth power
you're going to get to a super huge
number because this thing is just going
to keep skyrocketing up like that so let
me just draw the whole curve just make
sure you see it over here i'm not
actually on 0 all the way the way i drew
it it might look like that i'm slightly
above zero i'm increasing above that
increasing about that as once i get into
the positive x's then i start really
really shooting up